hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live der wagneraufstand in
Russland und die Folgen das ist heute
unser Thema und wir begrüßen Euch ganz
Herzlich dazu ihr werdet es mitbekommen
haben der Chef der berüchtigten Wagner
Söldner Truppe Jewgeni prigoshi er hat
sich gegen Moskau erhoben und hat mit
seinen Einheiten von der Ukraine aus
einige Gebiete so etwa auch die Stadt
Roßdorf nach eigenen Angaben unter seine
Kontrolle gebrachte sehen wir Bilder der
Stadt seine Kämpfer würden zudem das
Hauptquartier der russischen Armee für
den Süden Russlands kontrollieren dort
werden auch die Kämpfe in der Ukraine
überwacht Putin wiederum hat ihn
daraufhin zum Verräter erklärt und für
pregorian und seine Unterstützer hohe
Strafen in Aussicht gestellt außerdem
bereitet sich nur noch Moskau darauf vor
eventuell von Wagner Truppen angegriffen
zu werden denn so wie es aussieht sind
eben die Wagner Leute auch auf dem
Vormarsch auf die Hauptstadt viel
Gesprächsstoff also für unsere Gäste die
da heute sind der Osteuropa Experte
Andreas Umland Markus Korth
militärökonomen von der ETH Zürich und
zunächst unsere Moskau großbrandtin für
begab wie immer natürlich eure Fragen
und Kommentare gerne an uns per Mail er
sieht das eingeblendet oder über Social
Media aber bevor wir jetzt gleich in die
Diskussion mit unseren Gästen einsteigen
bringt uns zunächst meine Kollegin Nina
Niederberger auf den aktuellen Stand der
Dinge
es sind diese Szenen zu denen die
Menschen in Rostock am Donner Morgen
aufwachen Panzer auf den Straßen Wagner
Söldner die bis vor kurzem wohl noch in
der Ukraine gekämpft haben jetzt Fechten
sie für ihren Chef Jewgeni pregorian
einen Machtkampf aus mit dem
Verteidigungsministerium und mit
Präsident Wladimir Putin
wir sind im Hauptquartier in Rostock am
Don es ist 7:30 Uhr wir haben die
Militäranlagen und den Flughafen unter
unserer Kontrolle
die Stadt unter Kontrolle einer
Privatarmee die Menschen verängstigt
verwirrt
eine Frau fragt wird es einen
Bürgerkrieg geben nein alles wird gut
keine Sorge
ich weiß nicht bewaffnete Kräfte in
einer Stadt das ist schlecht es sollte
kein Militär hier in der Stadt sein
der Vormarsch angeblich Vergeltung für
einen tödlichen Angriff russischer
Truppen auf Wagner Soldaten pregorian
kündigt an bis nach Moskau vor Rücken zu
wollen
das bald auch auf diesen Straßen Panzer
der wagnergruppe Rollen will die
Regierungen Moskau unbedingt verhindern
mit Straßensperren verschärften
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen der
anti-terror-notstand wird ausgerufen
Putin meldet sich noch am Morgen aus dem
Kreml
das ist ein dollstoß in den Rücken
unseres Landes unseres Volkes diejenigen
die diesen militärischen Aufstand
vorbereitet haben haben Russland
verraten und werden dafür bestraft
am Mittag dann passieren die
wagnertruppen woroniesch auf halbem Weg
vom Süden in die Hauptstadt und bewegen
sich offenbar immer weiter Richtung
Moskau um deren Vormarsch zu stoppen
werden bei lieb jetzt 400 km vor der
Hauptstadt schon Straßenblockaden gebaut
der Machtkampf in Russland erspitzt sich
zu
ja also die Situation spitzt sich
zufälliger ist für uns in Moskau hallo
Vögel wir sprechen direkt mal über die
aktuelle Lage was sind deine
Informationen wie weit sind die Wagner
Truppen noch von Moskau entfernt
also vielleicht mal ganz kurz noch zu
einer anderen Entwicklung die sich in
den letzten Minuten getan hat Alexander
Lukaschenko der belarussische Machthaber
der hat sich über seinen Pressedienst zu
Wort gemeldet er sagt er habe mit
Jewgeni pregorien gesprochen und da habe
ihm klar gemacht dass dieser bewaffnete
Aufstand keine gute Idee sei und
pregorian habe daraufhin eingelenkt und
gesagt er werde den Vormarsch auf Moskau
stoppen ob Lukaschenko da recht hat oder
ob das wahr wird was er da ankündigt das
müssen wir jetzt mal abwarten ansonsten
sind die letzten offiziellen Meldungen
eben die dass die Wagner Truppen das
Gebiet von lieb jetzt erreicht haben und
sich von dort auf weiter Richtung Moskau
fortbewegen da sehen wir uns auch noch
mal auf der Karte also noch ist es ein
Stück aber eben die Richtung war
eindeutig Richtung Moskau also das wäre
natürlich ein ziemlicher Turner und wenn
diese Meldung die du gerade zitiert hast
stimmen sollte wir gehen jetzt aber mal
trotzdem weiter von dem Fall aus dass
die Wagner Truppen weitermachen mit
ihrem vor
vor Marsch auf Moskau wie bereitet sich
denn die russische Armee oder überhaupt
auch die Stadt auf diese Situation vor
wie ist die Atmosphäre dort
also hier wurde er heute morgen schon
das anti-terrorregime ausgerufen dass
das ermöglicht den Sicherheitsbehörden
zum Beispiel verschiedene Fahrzeuge zu
durchsuchen Sie auch zu beschlagnahmen
die Kommunikationswege abzuhorchen und
vieles mehr das ist das erste was
eingeführt wurde mittlerweile sehen wir
das Sandsäcke aufgestapelt werden an den
Zufahrtsstraßen Richtung Moskau zum
Beispiel vor allem natürlich denen die
aus dem Süden kommen und wir sehen auch
verschiedene Fahrzeuge die allerdings
eher nach Baustellenfahrzeugen Aussehen
der die auf Videos zu sehen sind und
scheinbar Straßen zerstören und so den
Vormarsch ähm aufhalten sollen ähm die
Sorge ist aber natürlich die dass falls
die Wagner Truppen näher an Moskau
heranrücken sollten oder sogar die
Hauptstadt erreichen dass es dann auch
von der Seite des russischen Militärs
mit härteren beschützen aufgefahren wird
wie schätzt du denn die Moskauer
Bevölkerung ein die Stimmung innerhalb
dieser Bevölkerung werden sie sich den
Wagner soll ten dann entgegenstellen
werden sie sich um Putin Scharen oder
ist er das Gegenteil anzunehmen
also die Stimmung hier in der Hauptstadt
die ist schon angespannt das merkt man
es geht es gehen unglaublich viele
Gerüchte hier durch die Reihen es wird
immer wieder spekuliert obwohl möglich
eben außer diesem anti-terrorregime auch
noch irgendwann das Kriegsrecht
ausgerufen wird aber dass sich die
Menschen dann den wagner-truppen in den
Weg stellen würden das glaube ich
eigentlich nicht jetzt hatte auch immer
wieder gesagt dass es ihm eben nicht
darum geht Zivilisten anzugreifen das
ist ja das was er eigentlich gerade
anklagt dass das russische
Verteidigungsministerium zu Lachs umgehe
mit Menschenleben dass dort Soldaten
angeblich in den Krieg geschickt werden
die nicht aus gut ausgerüstet sind nicht
gut ausgebildet sind er würde hatte also
mehrfach gesagt wer sich ihm nicht in
den Weg stellt der muss auch nichts
befürchten insofern glaube ich dass die
Moskau Bevölkerung da keine große Rolle
spielen wird gut sie Bevölkerung
vielleicht nicht aber könnte Putins
macht jetzt auch von anderen Personen
beispielsweise in seinem persönlichen
Umfeld aus dem Krem l von anderen
Personen in Frage gestellt werden wie
geschwächt ist er durch diese Ereignisse
es ist auf jeden Fall so dass diese
Ereignisse Spuren hinterlassen denn
Wladimir Putin des seine Macht hat sich
eigentlich in großen Teilen darauf
gegründet dass er eben als unangreifbar
galt und das ist immer so aussah als
habe er seine Zirkel um sich herum
erstens geschlossen und zweitens eben
auch so gut ausbalanciert dass die er
sich gegenseitig gefährlich werden als
ihm im Moment sieht es ja ist es ja auch
immer noch ein Machtkampf zwischen
der Wagner Truppe auf der einen Seite
und dem Verteidigungsministerium auf der
anderen Seite aber klar ist die Rolle
von Wladimir Putin jetzt schon die eines
geschwächten Präsidenten das Image dass
er so gerne von sich verbreitet das
unanfechtbaren Kreml Herrschers das
unantastbaren Gremmel Herrschers das hat
mindestens mal dicke Spitze bekommen ja
Informationen und Einschätzungen von für
begal live aus Moskau ganz herzlichen
Dank
und wir sprechen direkt weiter mit
Andreas Umland er ist Ost Europa Experte
kommt vom Stockholmer Zentrum für
Osteuropa Studien herum Land guten Abend
ich grüße Sie
guten Abend ja mit Blick auf das was da
gerade passiert wenn man vielleicht auch
noch mal die russische Gesellschaft
insgesamt so ein bisschen in den Blick
nehmen bzw auch die Machtstrukturen in
Moskau ist das schon so eine Art
Kartenhaus dass da jetzt in sich
zusammenfällt oder ist das noch zu früh
also zumindest ist es eine
Infragestellung des Bildes dass wir
haben vom Putin Regime das ist ja schon
im letzten Jahr ein Frage gestellt
worden mit dieser peinlichen Performance
der russischen Armee in der Ukraine und
jetzt stellt sich eben auch heraus dass
das politische System
dass er selber aufgebaut hat was er
quasi in Eigenregie geschaffen hat mit
diesen verschiedenen Gruppen jetzt auf
einmal in Spannung Gerät so das ist
glaube ich milde wenn man es milde
ausdrückt und
das glaube ich
illustriert auch ein bisschen die
Hoffnung die hier in der Ukraine
sprechen ja aus Kiew besteht das nämlich
diese Spannungen dann letztlich auch zu
dem führen was man dann hier in der
Ukraine als sie bezeichnet würde ja da
wollte ich gerade noch drauf eingehen
sie sind in Kiew uns zugeschaltet
deswegen auch vielleicht gerade mal die
Frage die Reaktionen in der Ukraine auf
das was dort in Russland passiert sind
ja vielleicht auch ganz interessant wie
wird das wahrgenommen
nun das wird natürlich sehr genau
verfolgt es gibt auch weiterhin
sozusagen enge Verbindungen viel engere
Verbindungen das wird meistens auch in
Deutschland oder im Westen vergessen
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland es
gibt also die gemeinsamen sozialen
Netzwerke insbesondere telegram die man
nutzt also die Ukraine verfolgen sehr
genau die
russischen telegram-kanäle die
Propaganda die militärblogger alles was
dort passiert auch in der russischen
Provinz passiert und das wird natürlich
als Chance jetzt wahrgenommen und im
Grunde als
Verwirklichung dessen was hier glaube
ich viele die letzten anderthalb Jahre
auch immer gehofft haben dass nämlich
militärische Erfolge der Ukraine dann
letztlich eben auch innenpolitische
Auswirkungen haben in Russland die dann
letztlich diesen Sieg auch möglich
machen wie schätzen sie denn die Dynamik
jetzt dieser Ereignisse in Russland ein
und wie gefährlich ist die Situation für
Putin gerade
also es ist eine neue Situation es gab
ja auch vorher schon russische Kritik an
Putin wir kennen am meisten die liberale
russische Kritik aber es gibt eben auch
russische Nationalisten die zum Beispiel
in der Ukraine quasi auf ukrainischer
Seite gegen Putin aus ihrem eigenen
ideologischen
Überzeugungen her kämpfen es gibt in
Russland es gab vorher schon vor
priorische in eine sehr intensive Kritik
auch russischer Nationalisten die auch
involviert waren zum Beispiel der 2014
im Grunde den Krieg begonnen hat das hat
er selber so auch ausgedrückt der also
seit Monaten schon ähm Putin beschimpft
aber das waren eben bisher immer Leute
ob nun ein liberale oder Nationalisten
die ähm
außerhalb des eigentlichen Regimes
standen während Priorin eine Kreatur
Putins ist und bis vor kurzem sozusagen
Fleisch vom Fleischer das putinsystems
war und nun sich auf einmal gegen Putin
oder zumindest den den
Verteidigungsminister und den
generalstaatschef gewendet hat und damit
das ganze System in Frage stellt das ist
eine neue Qualität auch wenn das jetzt
wenn der Spuk morgen vorbei sein sollte
ich weiß es nicht dann ist das natürlich
ein Bruch für das putinische System ich
lese mal ein paar Kommentare vor die uns
erreichen ähm schreibt über Youtube
diese spezialoperation läuft schon sehr
speziell Tore schreibt ich bin da leider
nicht so optimistisch wie alle anderen
es gibt hier viele Stimmen die sagen
dass sie damit sozusagen den Anfang des
Endes von Putins Regime gekommen sehen
er schreibt das sieht er nicht so
trotzdem schön dass in Russland das
Chaos regiert und immer wieder wird die
Frage aufgeworfen ja wem gelten denn
jetzt die Loyalitäten also
Frieden oder putin hatte tatsächlich das
Zeug Putin ernsthaft in Frage zu stellen
also zumindest bisher sieht es so aus
dass er tatsächlich enorme Ressourcen
kontrolliert er hat ja schon etliche
Provinzhauptstädte besetzt und ist bis
jetzt soweit mir bekannt immer noch auf
dem Vormarsch nach Moskau und das ist
eigentlich eine Entwicklung die hier
auch in der Ukraine in dieser Form kaum
jemand erwartet hat das geht eigentlich
über das hinaus was man sich erhofft
hatte ich denke hier war die Hoffnung
vor allen Dingen damit verbunden dass
wenn man die russische Besetzung der
krimin in Frage stellen würde zu durch
z.B die Isolierung der Krim dass das
dann in der in Russland innenpolitische
Auswirkungen haben würde und dann eben
die die Autorität Russlands beschädigen
würde aber jetzt ist die Ukraine im
Grunde noch weit von einem größeren
militärischen Sieg entfernt und und
schon auf diese Stufe gibt es jetzt
diese diese enormen Spannung innerhalb
des russischen Systems innerhalb der
russischen
Streitkräfte das ist eine auch hier für
die Ukraine glaube ich überraschende
Entwicklung wir bekommen immer wieder
Fragen rein ich hier über Youtube
schreibt was könnte die Ukraine oder der
besten entscheiden tun um pregorien
indirekt zu unterstützen und somit
Putins Russland weiter zu spalten
naja das ist ein Vorschlag mit den den
ich irgendwie verstehen kann aber ich
denke letztlich ist das eine
innerrussische Angelegenheit diese
Spannungen sind ganz eindeutig
hervorgerufen durch die Misserfolge
Russlands in der Ukraine also das ist
der große strukturelle Faktor der
dahinter steht wenn die wenn Russland in
der Ukraine militärisch erfolgreich sein
würde dann gäbe es natürlich diese
Meuterei pregorians nicht es gebe auch
nicht die vielen anderen Kritiker von
nationalistischer von imperialistischer
Seite aus aber trotzdem ist diese
Konflikt zwischen dem
Verteidigungsministerium und der
wagnergruppe jetzt eben doch eine sehr
innere russische Angelegenheit wo weder
die Ukraine noch Russland etwas weder
die Ukraine noch der Westen etwas
machen können sondern man kann dem
eigentlich nur zuschauen die Ukraine
kann jetzt natürlich die Schwächung der
Front die dadurch entstanden ist
ausnutzen für ihre Kriegsführung
soweit die Einschätzungen von Andreas
Umland vom Stockholmer Zentrum für
Osteuropa Studien ganz herzlichen Dank
dass Sie heute abend uns zur Verfügung
gestanden haben und wir spielen quasi
Ping Pong denn es geht noch mal zurück
zu Vögel garden in der Tat ist es wohl
so dass ich die Meldung die du gerade
schon zitiert hast Vögel bestätigen
vielleicht kannst du es gerade noch mal
sagen was ist der neueste Stand der
Dinge
also es fing ja damit an dass
Lukaschenko der belarussische Machthaber
gesagt hat er habe mit dem efgeni
pregorien gesprochen und ihn davon
überzeugt dass dieser militärische
Aufstand eine schlechte Idee sei und er
habe ihn zum einen lenken überreden
können und jetzt hat sich also gerade
vor wenigen Minuten in seinem Telegramm
Kanal wiederum zu Wort gemeldet mit
einer audiobo Botschaft und darin sagt
er tatsächlich ja wir kehren jetzt
zurück ähm wir drehen um
ja das ist in der Tat interessant das
würde jetzt bedeuten alles doch nicht so
heiß äh gegessen wie es gekocht wurde
oder also ich versuche mich gerade in
den Herrn ist natürlich schwierig
hineinzuversetzen aber was steckt die
jetzt dahinter und warum könnte er
womöglich jetzt gesagt haben okay ich
mache es doch nicht
es ist natürlich noch super früh um da
eine schlüssige Antwort darauf zu finden
aber es gab hier in den letzten Stunden
schon die ein oder andere Stimme die
immer mal wieder gewarnt hat und gesagt
hat das sieht doch irgendwie nach einem
abgekaterten Spiel aus vielleicht ist
das ganze eine Falle um die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte sozusagen irgendwohin zu
locken wo Sie denken dass eine Lücke an
der Front entstehen könnte durch diesen
vermeintlichen Abzug der Wagner Truppen
man muss ja auch sagen dass dieser
Vormarsch der Wagner Söldner relativ
geräuschlos verlief also Roßdorf haben
sie sehr schnell erreicht das Militär
Hauptquartier durch ohne größere Kämpfe
besetzen können vielleicht ähm sind das
alles Faktoren die man im Nachgang noch
mal kritischer betrachten müsste aber in
der Tat ist es natürlich so wie bewegen
uns da immer noch in einem relativ
spekulativen Bereich und es ist
natürlich auch schon öfter du hast es
gerade selber gesagt findiert worden das
gehört ja nun auch zu jedem Krieg dazu
also insofern vielleicht noch mal die
Frage an dich für wie glaubhaft hältst
du diese Entwicklung jetzt schon
es sicher ist es belastbar oder sind da
noch große Zweifel geboten
also die beiden Nachrichten sowohl die
von Lukaschenko als auch die von
pregorian die kamen auf den Kanälen wo
diese beiden Männer ihre Botschaften
normalerweise platzieren das ist jetzt
also nicht aus zweiter oder dritter
Quelle sondern das kommt von Lukaschenko
und von pregorian selbst insofern halte
ich das erstmal für belastbar aber
natürlich werden wir die Lage jetzt
weiter beobachten es steht ja auch noch
im Raum warum wenn Pädagogin jetzt
umdreht dann sabiani in der Moskauer
Bürgermeister wiederum erst vor
eineinhalb Stunden jetzt noch den Montag
zu einem arbeitsfreien Tag ausgerufen
hatte
vielen Dank noch mal für diese
Einschätzungen aus Moskau ich danke dir
dass du noch mal für uns zur Verfügung
entstanden ist und wir sprechen wieder
direkt weiter es ist hier ein munteres
Karussell mit
Herrn Kolb jetzt muss ich gerade noch
mal auf meinen Spickzettel gucken genau
Markus von der ETH Zürich ist uns
zugeschaltet Herr Kolberg ja das sind
Ereignisse die sich quasi hier
überschlagen wir dachten also es gibt
einen Vormarsch den kann es auch nach
wie vor geben es könnte aber eben auch
sein wir haben ja gerade die Kollegin
gehört das pregorien sozusagen sich
jetzt dagegen entschieden hat wie
schätzen Sie die Situation aktuell
man muss bei pregorsee natürlich immer
aufpassen weil er versteht sich sehr
sehr gut darauf seine eigene PR
voranzubringen und auch er hält sich
nicht immer anders was er so großflächig
ankündet ich kann mir vorstellen dass
das hängt logistisch einfach damit
zusammen wie die weitere Bewegung
aussieht es kommt nämlich also da wo er
jetzt steht in ungefähr 50 km ein sehr
großes Hindernis auf ihn zu nämlich der
Fluss UK der ist an dieser Stelle wo er
rüber muss etwa 200 m breit und es ist
durchaus möglich dass die Reste der
russischen inlandsverteidigung oder die
rostqualia dort vielleicht größere
sperren errichtet haben das Problem bei
preußischen Vorstoß ist einfach dass er
in Bewegung bleiben muss also sobald er
irgendwo stehen bleibt könnte es der
Luftwaffe so langsam gelingen ihn fest
zu nageln und ihn dann anzugreifen
das wäre einem eine mögliche ähm Weise
wie das wie das erklärt werden könnte
eine andere ist einfach dass man ihn
gestochen hat
also dass man eben irgendwas anbietet
von mir aus keine Ahnung du bekommst
jetzt irgendein Posten in der Regierung
oder du bekommst bevorzugte Zuteilung
von Material ist alles möglich
das Wesentliche was man sich aber im
Klaren sein muss über Russland ist in
Russland dürfen sie eines nicht zeigen
nämlich Schwäche und allein die Tatsache
dass ihr einfach nach Rostock nadoro
reingehen kann sich dieses Material
greifen und dann über 500 km einfach auf
Moskau fahren das lässt Putin
unglaublich schwach Aussehen zu mal
nicht nur den selber Moskau verlassen
hat sondern auch ein Teil seiner
Regierung und etliche Oligarchen
das zeigt Ihnen wie fragil dass das
ganze System ist jetzt können Sie
natürlich sagen okay das war alles ein
abgekartetes Theater aber das das glaube
ich nicht also Putin würde sowas
freiwillig nie machen das lässt ihn als
schwach und inkompetent da stehen und
ähm es ist möglich dass das vielleicht
auch nur zum Schein auf das ganze
eingeht also dass er jetzt irgendwo sich
ins Gelände verstreut sich dort
konsolidiert
und in ein paar Tagen geht das Ganze
weiter ja also das ist alles sehr
spannend und wie gesagt auch noch ein
bisschen spekulativ natürlich wir müssen
das weiter beobachten wollen aber
trotzdem natürlich jetzt auch schon mal
sprechen über die möglichen Auswirkungen
wenn es also bei diesem Putschversuch
bleiben sollte oder vielleicht gehen wir
noch mal kurz einen Schritt zurück
vielleicht erklären Sie auch unseren
Zuschauern noch mal was könnte überhaupt
was wird in aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach dazu bewogen haben überhaupt diesen
Putschversuch anzustrengen war das eine
spontane Aktion es gab ja schon länger
Kritik von ihm auch an Seiten der
militärischen Führung was was steckt
dahinter ihrer ihre Ansicht nach ja also
spontan war die auf keinen Fall also die
Art und Weise wie dieser Vorstoß
verläuft die logistische exakte die
Geschwindigkeit das lässt darauf
schließen dass er das seit Wochen
geplant hat
wir alle kennen ja mittlerweile seine
tödliche Freundschaft mit jojou und das
letzte was ja versucht hatte war im
Wagner zu zwingen diese Verträge zu
unterschreiben mit denen er sich
freiwillig freiwillig den ähm dem
russischen Verteidigungsministerium
Unterordner das hatte natürlich nicht
getan
und wenn Sie jetzt den Wagner Quellen
glauben dann haben die Russen selber
also die russische Armee am Freitagabend
erstmalig Wagner Depots bombardiert also
versucht Wagner logistisch auszuschalten
und das hat Pregarten dann
wahrscheinlich dazu gebracht zu sagen
okay jetzt jetzt muss ich All-In gehen
weil ansonsten werde ich neutralisiert
also soweit die Story wenn Sie den Pro
Wagner Kanälen glauben das tun wir jetzt
mal für den Moment und wenn sie jetzt
überlegen es ist vorhin gesagt worden
Wagner oder privat
Putins das stimmt nicht so ganz also
Wagner oder pregorien selber hat ein
Netzwerk von einflussreichen Freunden
die nicht von Putin abhängen ähm dazu
gehört zum Beispiel der Gouverneur von
Pula das wäre die nächste Oblast wo er
durch muss es ist also nicht so dass er
dass er vollständig von Putin abhängig
wäre aber er war in der Vergangenheit
von einem abhängig von einem nämlich von
den Lieferungen des russischen Militärs
also alles was Wagner eingesetzt hat die
ganze Logistik das ganze schwere
Material das kam alles vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium das heißt die
konnten Wagner so ein bisschen
kontrollieren ja die konnten ihn klein
halten indem sie zum Beispiel gesagt
haben du kriegst einfach nicht so viele
Artillerie Granaten oder du kriegst
einfach nicht so viel schweres Material
und scheuko hatte sich ja auch so seine
teuflische Freude dran zu beobachten wie
die wagnerkämpfer dann drauf gehen in an
der ukrainischen Front weil sie einfach
nicht genügend Material kriegen jetzt
hat sich das aber verändert jetzt hat er
nämlich heute morgen den zentralen
logistischen Knotenpunkt des südlichen
Milito in Beschlag genommen das heißt
also sämtliches Material sämtliche
Logistik die er da steht ist jetzt
Wagner Logistik und das wenn sie das
alles zusammenzählen also alles was da
rum steht in diesem südlichen
militärrezepte sind zwei mechanisierte
Divisionen das ist also nicht wenig
Material also auch von daher erscheint
es mir so ein bisschen seltsam dass er
jetzt freiwillig quasi schon wieder
aufgeben
sollte uns und sich zurückziehen die
Gewaltmittel nach Gau hinein zu
marschieren die hätte er ganz sicher
jetzt muss man ein drittes Element
Bedenken alles was Russland an schweren
Mitteln hat sofort alles steht in der
Ukraine sofern es noch da ist also
sofern es nicht durch die Gewalthandlung
aufgegangen ist das heißt also russland
hat diesen Vormarsch eigentlich nichts
entgegenzusetzen an schwere Material das
einzige was noch in Moskau also in der
blast und Stadt selber
weil die zivile Polizei in Moskau die
kann sowas nicht abwehren und angenommen
es würde Wagner auch noch gelingen sich
wieder Daria zu verbinden da wäre das
Putin Regime am Ende jetzt frage ich Sie
jemand der so stark steht wieso sollte
der sich freiwillig wieder zurückziehen
sieht alles ein bisschen inkonsistent
aus ja das sind interessante
Informationen die Sie damit uns teilen
und in der Tat fragt man sich fast
dahinter steckt das wirkt alles noch
nicht so ganz klar ich versuche noch mal
einige Fragen unserer User zu bündeln
und in die Sendung mit aufzunehmen ich
gefragt uns über Youtube werden wir mit
einer Schlacht um Moskau noch 2023 zu
rechnen haben wenn ja welche Einheiten
würden puti dann überhaupt noch zur
Verfügung stehen das ist das eine und
Pascal fragt ist es möglich dass dieser
Putsch zu einem Bürgerkrieg führt wie
würden sie diese Fragen beantworten ja
also zur ersten Frage Schlacht um Moskau
würde ich nicht sagen weil dafür ist
Moskau einfach viel zu groß also wenn
Sie wenn Sie bedenken 10% aller
russischen Einwohner wohnen alleine in
Moskau das ist eine Metropole von 14
Millionen in also man das ist nicht
bachmut das ist eine komplett andere
komplett andere Level also man würde
selbst wenn Sie jetzt damit 400 schweren
Fahrzeugen reingehen das würde bei
weitem nicht ausreichen um so eine
Metropole auch nur annähern zu
kontrollieren der Effekt ist viel mehr
im psychologischer also sie zeigen dass
sie nach Moskau hineinfahren können
damit lassen sie das Putin Regime
schwach aussehen und wie gesagt nichts
ist in Russland tödlicher als schwach
auszusehen oder Schwäche zu zeigen und
das könnte dann dazu führen dass
verschiedene Elemente des putin-regimes
wie zum Beispiel die Oligarchen oder wie
zum Beispiel die zivilepolizei sagen
okay offenbar ist Putin nicht mehr der
nationic also der hat hier nichts mehr
zu sagen also
treten wir einfach jetzt zur Seite und
lassen Wagner hinfahren wo auch immer
sich hinfahren möchten
insofern glaube ich glaube ich das nicht
was sie heute allerdings gesehen haben
ist dass die roswardian Stellungen
bezogen hat an verschiedenen Einfall äh
Straßen die nach Moskau hineinführen man
kann sich Moskau so ein bisschen
vorstellen wie Paris ist also eine
extrem zentralisierte Stadt in die
verschiedenen Achsen aus den
Himmelsrichtungen einfach hineinfahren
und man kann sich auch so ein bisschen
vorstellen wie München es gibt einen
inneren Stadtring und einem großen
äußeren stadtringen für die äußere
Stadtautobahn und sobald sie sobald sie
da drauf sind können sie eigentlich in
beliebiger Richtung nach Moskau
hineinfahren ich denke das ist das
worauf Wagner abzielt also diesen
psychologischen Effekt er kann nach
Moskau rein und dann wäre wirklich die
Frage wie verhält sich die aus Claudia
also würde die anfangen Wagner zu
beschließen dann käme es möglicherweise
zu solchen Scharmützeln an dieser
Stadtring Autobahn aber der Großteil der
Zivilbevölkerung in Moskau würde das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mitbekommen er
würde die russische Luftwaffe Eingreifen
der ist vielleicht noch was anderes die
bürgerkriegsgefahr vielleicht noch kurz
wie sehen Sie die Burger Kings gefahren
würde ich auch nicht sagen weil wir
haben es hier nicht mit einem Burger
King zu tun sondern wir müssen bedenken
Russland ist ein mafiöser Start der
unter der Kontrolle einer besonders gut
organisierten Gruppe steht nämlich jetzt
also dieser dieser Gruppe von ehemaligen
KGB und FFP Offizieren die sich den
russischen Staat quasi angeeignet haben
und diese Leute haben auch die Gewalt
Mittel und diese Leute wiederum die
haben Bündnisse mit anderen Fraktionen
wie zum Beispiel eine lol egalischen mit
mit Polizei generellen und so weiter
also alles eine sehr heterogene Mischung
aber die Zivilbevölkerung spielt da
eigentlich überhaupt keine Rolle also
das man kann sich das so ein bisschen
vorstellen wie Game of Thrones ist in
verschiedene mächtige Fraktion die
Gewalt haben und kämpfen um Macht oder
um Ressourcen aber die Zivilbevölkerung
ist dem Gegenüber eigentlich völlig
passiv sie weder unterstützt Sie diese
Leute noch stellt sie sich ihnen
entgegen das heißt was passieren würde
ist die eine Fraktion tritt ab und die
andere Fraktion übernimmt die Macht die
cd-bevölkerung würde aber nicht groß
gestört werden also es käme dann auch
nicht so zu großen Kampfhandlungen in
ganz Russland aber was passiert könnte
ist eine interne
Destabilisierung oder Desintegration das
heißt also dass manche Provinzen oder
manche für raten in der Russischen
Föderation sagen könnten okay putin ist
jetzt hier nicht mehr Chef also wir
machen uns selbständig haben wir
erklären uns unabhängig oder wir nehmen
künftig keine Befehle mehr aus Moskau
entgegen das würde dann aber eher
politisch ablaufen also nicht nicht als
militärischer Konflikt sondern sie sagen
aber
weitreichenden Folgen wenn ich wieder
richtig verstehe also das wäre für mich
eine Veränderung
müssen wir uns einstellen also es gab
heute einen ehemaligen deutschen
Diplomaten der gesagt hat es geht doch
nicht Russland darf nicht zerfallen ja
sonst dem Motto sie müssen den Zerfall
des Imperiums beim Auswärtigen Amt
anmelden ja so läuft das aber nicht sie
müssen sich vorstellen Russland ist so
ein bisschen was wie Österreich Ungarn
ja es ist etwas sehr sehr fragiles
komplexes multi-ethnisch multireligiös
von tiefgreif Spannungen und
Widersprüchen durchzogen und sie haben
nicht nur die klassischen Kandidaten wie
wie Tschetschenien sie haben auch
Kandidaten
Osten und alle die könnten auf Ideen
kommen und deswegen noch mal deswegen
habe ich am Anfang gesagt sie können
dieses Imperium nur zusammenhalten wenn
sie Stärke zeigen in dem Moment wo sie
Schwäche zeigen ihn sofort diese
zentrifuganen tendenzenlos das haben wir
immer wieder gesehen in der russischen
Geschichte da würde ich gerne noch mal
einen Haken weil dieser Punkt Stärke
zeigen bzw Schwäche zeigen wird auch von
unseren Usern aufgegriffen Mister gläden
fragt uns wie kann brigoshi das
Überleben der kann doch nicht einfach so
weitermachen das kann Putin nicht
zulassen aus den Gründen die Sie gerade
genannt haben also hat er sich jetzt
selber damit die Schlinge um den Hals
gelegt oder wie muss man sich das
vorstellen ja das sehe ich ganz ehrlich
also auch mit dem was was pregorian auf
seinem eigenen Telegramm Kanal
geschrieben hat also heute morgen sie
können es mal nachlesen wenn Sie möchten
hat wörtlich geschrieben russland hat
bald einen neuen Präsidenten wenn sie
sowas schreiben im Putin Regime dann ist
klar da können sie nicht mehr
zurückrufen
also wenn ich mir das jetzt vorstelle
wie wie ist danach eine Existenz von
trikotin möglich also sicherlich in
Russland und im Ausland auch nicht er
ist viel zu prominent man würde ihn
finden und dort ermorden also was was
für eine Art Deal könnte er könnte er
haben also es wäre nur eine Art Deal
denkbar wo er wo er in das Pudding
Regime zurück ähm korruptiert wird aber
selbst dann steht tot in schwach da also
wenn er sowas unwidersprochen stehen
lässt auch mit der rede dir heute morgen
gehalten hat mit diesen endlosen
historischen Bezügen die er immer bringt
das ist gar nicht denkbar er würde dann
dastehen als der Mann der von von
trikotin gedemütigt wurde wie soll er
sowas politisch überleben das habe ich
wirklich keine Antwort drauf ja auch
gerade noch mal zur Einordnung der der
aktuellen Ereignisse Geschehnisse Daniel
thunderstil oder Daniel fragt uns gibt
es aktive Kämpfe derzeit zwischen
russischer Armee und Wagner Sölden
Söldnern wir kriegen die sich im Moment
tatsächlich und auf welcher Seite steht
dann Ramsan kadirov das ist ja auch ein
Jahr eine ganz berüchtigte Figur in
diesem ganzen Szenario welchen Einfluss
hat er welche Rolle könnte er da jetzt
noch spielen ja also ich sage erstmal
was zu den Kämpfen die gab es heute den
ganzen Tag über also wenn Sie wenn Sie
die verlustliste bis jetzt
zusammenzählen sind sechs russische
Kampfhubschrauber und zwei russische
Kampflugzeuge abgeschossen worden also
das war offenbar der Versuch der der
russischen Truppen den Wagner konnte aus
der Luft anzugreifen also diese Kämpfe
gab es und gibt es wahrscheinlich auch
weiterhin wenn Sie jetzt
das Bataillon anschauen also die die KD
rauszieht die heute vor ungefähr zwei
Stunden eingerückt sind in Rostock
nadonna da ist auch etwas Überraschendes
passiert nämlich nichts jetzt müssen sie
denken Wagner und KD auf die hassen sich
gegenseitig nicht nur weil na weil in
Wagner sehr starke neonazistische Motive
eine Rolle spielen und in denen sind
sowas wie Tschetschenen also wie sage
ich das jetzt diplomatisch Russen
zweiter Klasse bestenfall
und außerdem hat ja gar nicht auf sich
heute morgen öffentlich für Putin
erklärt und gesagt ich drücke jetzt mit
meinem heldenhaften tiktok Bataillon
hier gegen vor ja hatte auch gemacht der
ist nach Rostock nur reingefahren und
dann ist nichts passiert jetzt wäre
meine Frage wieso fangen die nicht an
aufeinander zu schließen
und ich halte es für denkbar dass
vielleicht bringt ihn selber zu sagt ja
aber warum sollst du dich für ein
bestehendes regime-opfern tue ich doch
lieber mit mir zusammen oder erkläre ich
für neutral oder fahr zurück nach
Tschetschenien erkläre ich dort zum
lokalen Gouverneur von Tschetschenien
und und herrsche dort in Frieden und was
in Moskau passiert ist musste ich nicht
mehr nicht mehr interessieren also
verstehen sie die diese komische
Mischung die die kadier auf die sind
jetzt in Rostock nadonna und sie machen
dort nichts das passt auch irgendwie
nicht zusammen das riecht auch irgendwie
so nach nach Deal oder nach Absprachen
ja also viele Ungereimtheiten die uns da
noch begegnen und wie gesagt also es
bleibt jetzt spannend die nächsten
Stunden und Tage natürlich abzuwarten
wir müssen jetzt sprechen auf der Basis
dessen was halt bislang passiert ist da
vielleicht noch mal die Frage könnte der
Putschversuch auch zu einer Meuterei
unter regulären Soldaten führen von
denen die meisten ja wahrscheinlich auch
nicht unbedingt freiwillig in der
Ukraine kämpfen oder zumindest auch
vielleicht Bestrebungen haben na ja die
Front sobald es geht wieder zu verlassen
ja also man muss jetzt sehen die
russischen Soldaten die in der Ukraine
sind die die Leben natürlich in einer
informations Bubble das heißt die die
bekommen hauptsächlich Propaganda
gefüttert ich würde sagen die sind im
Moment verwirrt aber nicht unbedingt
informiert es ist schon richtig dass
natürlich viele gemerkt haben dass sie
einfach verheizt werden als als
Kanonenfutter und entsprechende Motiv
haben die Ukraine zu verlassen ich denke
aber das Hauptproblem ist sind nicht die
russischen Gruppen in der Ukraine des
Hauptproblem ist wie deren Führung sich
jetzt orientiert und ich sage ja immer
wieder sie dürfen sich die russische
Armee nicht vorstellen als geschlossenes
System dass das eine einheitliche
Führung hat dass das einheitlich agiert
sondern es ist mehr eine Ansammlung von
verschiedenen Fraktionen oder von von
verschiedenen mächtigen Menschen die
diese unterschiedlich Interessen haben
und sich teilweise auch gegenseitig
bekämpfen und die die wichtigere Frage
wäre jetzt zum Beispiel wie stehen die
Kommandeure der verschiedenen
militärbezirke Russlands zu dieser
Bewegung weil diese Kommandeure die
haben letztlich die Logistik für das
ukraineische
ukrainische Kampfführung unter sich also
das gilt besonders für den südlichen
Militärbezirk dessen Ressourcen sind
jetzt Wagner aber auch für den
westlichen Bezirk dann ist die Frage was
machen die lokalen
russischen Kommandeure in der Ukraine
weil wenn Russland entschuldigen wenn
Wagner jetzt die gesamte Logistik von
rostovnadono unter sich hat dann heißt
das die gesamte kopfführung in der
Ukraine hängt jetzt an der Gnade von
Wagner also wenn Wagner sagt über
Rostock bzw krass oder das sind die
beiden logistischen Kanäle über die
kommt jetzt nichts mehr rein in die
Ukraine dann stehen die da ohne
Nachschub ohne Treibstoff ohne
Artillerie Granaten die wollen sie dann
kämpfen gegen die russische gegen die
ukrainische gegen offen sind schließlich
jedenfalls noch wichtiger ja können Sie
jetzt auf die Idee kommen also lokaler
russische Kommandeur ich mache hier
nicht mehr mit ich gehe einfach raus
Ukraine zurück nach Russland drei
vielleicht selber in diese Kämpfe ein
wie wollen Sie das machen sie können die
Ukraine im Moment nicht verlassen weil
Wagner die Logistik kontrolliert genau
da gibt es eine Frage die da ganz gut
passt auch von von hier noch mal auf
Youtube wäre prigos Sieg dann auch ein
indirekter Sieg wenn wir jetzt schon von
Sieg sprechen für die Ukraine geben wir
dann zu den möglichen
Friedensverhandlungen also ist das eine
denkbare Möglichkeit also sie sollten
sich zunächst mal von der Illusion lösen
das ist sowas wie Friedensverhandlungen
geben wird das wird das nicht geben es
wird höchstens ein Abzug der Ukraine der
der russischen Truppen aus der Ukraine
geben aber die werden sicher nicht
miteinander verhandeln
aber
wäre das denkbar
denkbar wäre es aber sie sie landen dann
letztlich wieder bei der Frage der
Logistik
macht es macht es im Moment logistisch
Sinn für die Russen da zu bleiben
was ist die Alternative die Alternative
ist abzuziehen und damit der
ukrainischen gegen Offensive erst recht
Vorschub zu bringen also ich denke die
die hauptsächliche Schwächung liegt
wirklich in diesem propagandistischen
Motiv dass das Putin schwach erscheinen
lässt aber wenn sie schon über die
Ukraine reden also es gibt nach ich
betonen nach unbestätigten Berichten
gibt es derzeit eine ukrainischen
Vorstoß und zwar nicht wo wir ihn alle
erwarten in SAP ja sondern im Krieg kann
also an der Tonne Front und ich habe die
letzten paar Tage auf Twitter immer
geschrieben guckt nicht nicht nur das
aber richtig er schaut auch aufgrund und
ich denke das ist vielleicht so das geht
in die Richtung von der von der User
Frage die Ukraine sagt okay wir wissen
nicht wie lange dieses Theater geht aber
wir nutzen diese momentane Verwirrung
jetzt aus um einfach vorzustoßen weil
wenn Sie die russischen Truppen ein paar
Tage binden können ob die kriegen keinen
logistischen Nachschub weil Wagner
irgendwie seine Spielchen spielt dann
könnte das tatsächlich gefährlich werden
und dann könnt ihr die Ukraine
vielleicht lokale Front Durchbrüche
erzielen ich lese gerade noch mal einen
Kommentar vor von Gabe Youtube ja ob die
russische Bevölkerung sich jetzt von
Putin abwenden wird bei dem ganzen Drama
in und um ihr Landes ist doch alles
peinlich das merken doch auch die
Menschen also wieder die Frage nach
Stärke Schwäche bzw der Glaubwürdigkeit
vielleicht die Putin noch hat in seinem
Land vielleicht noch mal ihre
abschließende Bemerkung dazu ähm wie
schätzen Sie jetzt die nächsten Stunden
Tagen ein für Putin wird das jetzt
richtig eng wie wie ist ich würde sagen
der User unterliegt vielleicht der
Annahme dass die russische Bevölkerung
sich jemals Putin zugewandt hat und da
würde ich sagen das ist heute nicht mehr
der Fall das war mal so also vor 2011
als Putin so den Nimbus hatte ist der
große Retter der uns aus dem Chaos der
den Nachkriegs Entschuldigung der Nacht
jetzt in Epoche und auch der Finanzkrise
herausgelöst hat aber seither also in
den letzten zehn Jahren ist die
russische Bevölkerung eigentlich immer
passiver geworden das heißt sie
unterstützt das Regime nicht sie macht
aber auch nichts dagegen sondern sie
sagt einfach was die hohen Herren da im
Moskau spielen das interessiert uns
nicht weiter und diese Passivität die
ist eigentlich typisch für dieses
mafiöse russische System
sie greifen sich die Ressourcen was mit
der Zivilbevölkerung interessiert ist
das ist Ihnen eigentlich egal ob die
lebt oder stirbt habe dass sie haben die
Ressorts und die Zivilbevölkerung
antwortet darauf halt mit einer gewissen
Passivität und das Recht sich jetzt weil
im Putin diese diese
zivilgesellschaftlichen Ressourcen nicht
mobilisieren kann also sie werden
sicherlich mit fliegenden fahren kommen
und sagen hier unser dialogger den
müssen wir jetzt retten ähm das heißt
wie die nächsten Tage aussehen wird sich
sehr stark daran orientieren wie die
Machthaber also die Inhaber
militärischer Gewaltmittel sich
entscheiden werden Sie weiterhin
das russische Regime stützen oder werden
sie es nicht und da würde ich vor allem
auf die Kommandeure der Militär bisher
geschauen und auf die Rose
die Analyse von Markus Kolb
militärökonom von der ETH Zürich wie
immer äußerst kenntnisreich es war eine
Freude ihnen zuzuhören vielen Dank dass
Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben heute
Abend und uns hier ein bisschen Licht
ins Dunkel bringen konnten danke schön
danke sehr schönen Abend noch danke auch
und ja an euch natürlich auch ein ganz
herzliches Dankeschön noch ein Hinweis
von mir jederzeit gibt's natürlich auch
die neuesten Informationen auf ZDF
heute.de die ganze Lage ist ja immer
noch sehr dynamisch oder eben auch mit
unserer App und um 20:15 Uhr also in
einer Viertelstunde gibt's ein heute
journal Spezial ganz klassisch im ZDF
Fernsehen das noch für Euch mit auf den
Weg vielen Dank für eure Interesse euch
noch ein schönes restliches Wochenende
und bis demnächst ciao ciao